-Russian president
Vladimir Putin rattled the world
by raising the alert status
of Russia's nuclear forces
as Republicans here at home
gathered
for the Conservative
Political Action Conference,
who refused to condemn
Donald Trump
for praising Putin's "genius."
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
It really feels like everywhere
you look these days,
the world is at the whims
of fully insane people.
Like, on top of everything else
that's going on right now,
I'm so mad that I have to care
what Marjorie Taylor Greene,
of all people, says and does.
This is a person who, at best,
should have her picture
on the door of a Ruby Tuesday
below the words "do not admit"
because she tried to steal feta
from the salad bar.
And yet, depressingly,
I have to care
because a large portion
of the Republican Party
is defending
or even celebrating her,
despite, just as one
of many recent examples,
her participation in
a white nationalist conference.
In fact, this weekend, she also
did a truly
head-spinning interview
where she defended her attempt
to help Trump overturn
the election on January 6th
and doubled down on the big lie
that the election was stolen,
while essentially admitting
she had no proof.
-I proudly objected
on January 6th.
I would object again today
because I know for a fact
there was so much wrong
in that election
and I believe it was stolen.
Do I know how?
No, I don't know how.
-No, you don't.
Well, don't let that stop you.
If you were at the zoo and one
of the attendants was like,
"Alright, kids, I'm going to
feed this poisonous cobra,
but fair warning --
I don't know how,"
you'd go to the aquarium, right?
I would also love for Greene
to stay out of the news,
because every time I see
her initials in an e-mail,
I think I have a meeting,
and I hate meetings,
especially our annual meeting
with the 30 Rock fire marshal.
Let me guess, in case of a fire,
we still take the stairs?
Because no one will listen
to my 30 Rock fire pole idea,
even though tourists
would love that.
What's that?
You want me to leave the meeting
because I'm a distraction?
Well, joke's on you because
I never wanted to be here
in the first place.
Where was I?
Oh, right, she's crazy.
Greene was at CPAC
mingling with the leading lights
and weirdest weirdos
of the modern GOP, like Trump,
Ron DeSantis, Ronny Jackson,
the former White House doctor
who said Trump had the brain
of Albert Einstein
and height and build
of a college linebacker,
and, of course,
the MyPillow guy, Mike Lindell,
who has a habit of popping up
at these conservative events
like Mickey Mouse at the Grand
Floridian breakfast buffet,
which is fitting since
Lindell's actual head
is the size of a mascot head.
One day, he's going to
pull it off
to reveal an underpaid
high school student.
"Hey, I never believed
in any of that stuff."
You might remember that Lindell
was famously photographed
carrying papers
into the White House
days before Trump left office
that said something about
declaring martial law.
At CPAC over the weekend,
a reporter tried to ask him
where he got those papers from,
and much like
Marjorie Taylor Greene,
he admitted
he didn't actually know
what the hell
he was talking about.
-That picture will go down
in history.
I'm helping save this country.
-Who gave you the papers?
-Who gave me the papers?
That's none of your business.
A bunch of lawyers did.
I've never read them --
-John Eastman?
-Hold it.
I've never read them.
I went in there with evidence
on January 15th.
You guys are old news.
You're regurgitating old news.
January 15th, I went in there
with four papers
that shows Dominion and the
election crime of the machines
and China attacking
our country --
cyberattack -- all 50 states,
over 12 million votes
that Donald Trump won
by 82 million to 68 million,
was the real count.
-But who gave you the papers
that advocated martial law?
-A whole bunch of lawyers did.
I've never read them.
-Alright.
First of all, who would buy
a pillow from a man
who has so obviously
never slept?
Secondly, if you're going to
make legal claims,
I feel like you should use
slightly more precise language
than the phrase
"a whole bunch of lawyers,"
especially since
the correct term
for a group of lawyers
is a hernia.
Pack of wolves, pride of lions,
hernia of lawyers.
Everyone knows that.
Also, let me see
if I follow this story.
A whole bunch of lawyers
just handed you some papers
about overturning the election
and declaring martial law.
And you brought them
to the White House
and showed them to the president
without reading them.
[ As Lindell ] Mr. President,
here's a whole pile of papers
I haven't read,
and they're out of order
because I dropped them
a few times on my way.
I also spilled a full cup
of coffee on every page,
but they're totally real.
I got them from a bunch
of legal-type people
who told me
they're basically lawyers,
except they haven't passed
da bar.
[ High-pitched voice ]
I'm so sorry.
[ Normal voice ]
The interview, believe it
or not, got crazier from there,
because Lindell then whipped up
a crowd of bystanders
into chanting the word "traitor"
at the reporter,
and by crowd,
I mean like two guys.
-Traitor, traitor, traitor!
Traitor, traitor! CBS.
Robert Costa is a traitor
to the United States of America.
-I'm not.
I'm trying to --
-No, you're a traitor.
This is old news
you regurgitate.
You care about --
Why do you protect
a company called Dominion
and you attack a company
called MyPillow?
You're a traitor to our country.
You're disgusting.
Traitor, traitor,
traitor, traitor!
-Alright, first of all,
I didn't notice until that time
he looks at his name tag
before he calls him a traitor.
[ As Lindell ]
You're a traitor...Robert Costa.
[ Normal voice ] Also,
you made it really easy
to attack MyPillow
when you named it MyPillow.
It's just a mistake
to put a possessive adjective
in a product name,
because as soon
as someone buys it,
it technically becomes
their pillow.
I feel like this
is a conversation
you're not yet willing
or even capable of having,
but when things calm down,
I'd love to loop back.
Second, I'm not sure I've ever
heard a less impressive chant.
It's like when two drunk guys
at a baseball game
try to get the wave going
and no one else is on board.
My favorite version is when
someone at Fenway Park
gets hammered
and then has muscle memory
to a previous game
when they did the wave.
[ Boston accent ] Hey, kid,
why don't you wave yourself
to the [bleep] parking lot?
You're done, kid.
[ Normal voice ] Imagine having
these fully insane people
anywhere near the levers
of power right now
as Russia threatens to escalate
its already brutal and horrific
invasion of Ukraine.
In response to a series
of punishing sanctions
from the West,
Russian president Vladimir Putin
terrified the entire world
by putting his nuclear forces
on high alert over the weekend.
-Vladimir Putin
is not backing down
and is escalating tensions
with the West.
He ordered Russian nuclear
forces be placed on high alert,
citing sanctions and aggressive
statements by NATO.
It raises fears
the conflict could spiral
into a nuclear attack.
-Okay, look, I know we all hear
the words "nuclear attack"
and freak out, but I'm sure
everything's going to be fine.
Do I know how?
-No, I don't know how.
[ Laughter ]
Still...
It's important to just stay calm
and follow responsible sources
who aren't making
outrageous claims
or doing outrageous things.
Like, for example,
yesterday I very calmly
called up the president of NBC
and asked them if 30 Rock
has a bunker, and they said,
"You can have a spot
in the bunker or a fire pole,"
and I yelled, "Fire pole!"
really fast, which I now regret.
Still, it's going to be kickass
when I have to evacuate.
Then I circled back and I said,
"A spot in the bunker?
So one exists?"
And they said, "Yes.
But there's only room
for essential late-night staff,
like Lorne, Jimmy Fallon,
and Wally."
-Yeah, sorry, Seth.
It's true.
They want me in the bunker.
-But why?
-Seth, I do cue cards for "SNL."
Plus, they said
if you get nuked,
I can do a show from the bunker
called "Late Night
with the Cue Card Guy."
[ Cheers and applause ]
I know.
This has been "A Cue-ser Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-Pretty robust applause there,
everybody.
[ Laughter ]
Also, who said it was okay to
make him the graphics package?
The point is,
lest you, for even a moment,
thought that interlude
with Wally was the point,
the point is,
Putin is lashing out
and threatening the unthinkable
in response
to a series of intense sanctions
and other punishments
from the West.
And even his closest
military officials
seem incredibly uncomfortable
taking these orders from him.
-We've seen very clearly
this week
that Putin is isolated
from his own officials.
We're talking about the order
for the nuclear alert.
When he gave this order
yesterday in the Kremlin,
he was sitting with his two
top military officials,
the defense minister and
the chief of the general staff.
And they weren't allowed
to get within 15 feet of them.
They were sat at the other end
of one of these
comically huge tables
that Putin makes people
sit at in the Kremlin.
The way that he summons
these officials
sitting at these huge distances
from him
around these ludicrous tables,
a lot of them look
visibly uncomfortable.
-Okay, first of all,
look at this table.
[ Laughter ]
That table is insane.
Dude, if you're worried
about COVID,
I have terrible news
about nuclear fallout.
[ Russian accent ]
Mr. President,
first warhead has exploded.
[ As Putin ]
Give me mask -- N96.
[ Laughter ]
Is better by one.
So get joke.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Also, look at the faces
of his two top
military officials
as he was giving them
the nuclear order this weekend.
They look like
they just turned the key
to start the nuclear countdown,
but instead it opened a door
to a room where their parents
were having an orgy.
[ Russian accent ]
Sergei, look away.
[ Normal voice ] The point is,
no one, not even, apparently,
Putin's own officials,
is watching this horrific war
and the humanitarian catastrophe
that is unfolding right now
and thinking, "Gee,
this Putin guy is a genius."
Wait, hold on.
Oh, damn it, I forgot.
I forgot there was
a Trump clip coming.
What's that?
There's always a Trump coming?
But are we sure that's fair?
I mean, he's a former president
just trying to enjoy
a quiet retirement.
Yeah, like, why don't we
just leave him alone?
What's that?
Oh, the clip is from his speech
at the Conservative
Political Action Conference,
where he gave the strongest
hints yet he might run again?
And in that same speech,
he doubled down
on his praise of Putin?
Alright, well, then roll
the clip [bleep]
-Yesterday, reporters asked me
if I thought
President Putin was smart.
I said, "Of course, he's smart,"
to which I was greeted with,
"Oh, that's such
a terrible thing to say."
I like to tell the tru--
Yes, he's smart.
The NATO nations
and indeed the world,
as he looks over
what's happening strategically
with no repercussions
or threats whatsoever,
they're not so smart.
They're looking
the opposite of smart.
"If you take over Ukraine,
we're going to sanction you,"
they say.
"Sanction?"
Well, that's a pretty weak
statement.
Putin is saying, "Oh,
they're going to sanction me?
They've sanctioned me
for the last 25 years.
You mean I can take over
a whole country
and they're
going to sanction me?
You mean they're not going to
blow us to pieces,
at least psychologically?"
-Nothing is funnier than
a person saying you're not smart
and then the best way
they can come up
to describe
the opposite of smart
are the words
"opposite of smart."
[ Laughter ]
Also, what the hell
are you talking about,
blow Putin to pieces
psychologically?
What do you want us to do?
Get him high
and play "Dark Side of the Moon"
synced up to "The Wizard of Oz"?
"Whoa, this [bleep] blowing me
to pieces psychologically.
Vasily, how about you?
You super high?"
[ Russian accent ] Well, man,
I cannot feel toes right now.
[ Normal voice ] And, yeah,
all my Russian accents
are going to sound the same.
But just remember, the better
my Russian accents get,
the worse things are going.
In fact,
if you ever watch this show
and find yourself saying,
"Seth's Russian accent's
getting better and better,"
that's when you need
to head to the bunker
or, if you're in 30 Rock,
the fire pole.
Fire pole's going to be
a huge hit, guys.
The world is aghast
at Russia's brutal
and horrific invasion of Ukraine
and its threats of escalation,
including the thousands
of ordinary Russians
who've taken to the streets and
been arrested for protesting.
What we need now,
more than anything,
is to ignore the deranged rants
of reckless morons like Trump
and do everything possible
to help the refugees,
support the Ukrainian people,
and find a peaceful path
toward de-escalation.
Send whoever you need to send --
diplomats, ambassadors,
or, hell, maybe even...
-A whole bunch of lawyers.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.